hallo leute ich bin imker und bei mir
sind liam und leser bett wir besuchen
heute die namen ambris ist ein brauerei
mit uns ist
das hier haben wir auf dem elste gäste
am anfang bevor wir unsere gäste von
mails sieht es so aus
so leicht und wenn es fertig gemeldet
ist dann sieht es so aus
und du kannst wie es
ja ja sagen wir das mal transportiert
das ist jetzt die steuer raum wo wir die
ganze anlage mit dem putter steuern und
was kontrolliert alles auch auf dem pc
sind wir jetzt
jetzt sind wir in der su aus das ist wo
wir unsere wirtschaft bevor wir unsere
wie vor der gärung wir wo wir unsere
wirte herstellen
da braucht man für die beine stellen
unser wäre sieht alles alle reinartz
geburt wäre deswegen brauchen wir nur
wasser hopfen malz und hefe
was wir gerade sehen das sind die leeren
dosen die fahren über diese brücke
hinten zum dosen cola die leere bierdose
kommt oben durch diese rutsche runter in
diesem kleinen plexiglas gehäuse wird
sie noch mal ausgespielt wenn sie unten
ankommt ist sie mittlerweile leer
gedruckt also sauber und trocken wird
dann umgedreht mit der öffnung nach oben
ab und knallt sie auch und wir dann in
den füller eingewiesen gemacht eine
umdrehung kommt voll raus bekommt seinen
deckel drauf und geht weiter
wie lange die bestellung der bär dauert
so ungefähr bis drei wochen ist er
fertig ist alles abhängig von der sorte
und da sind viele faktoren warum
sprechen sie so gut deutsch
ich habe bei guter zentrum angefangen
deutsch zu lernen und dann bin ich nach
deutschland für neun monaten mein
studium zu machen und da bin ich auch
mit viele deutsche leute unterwegs und
halten und immer wir brauerei ist auch
meistens deutsche leute so meine
mitarbeiter sind alle fast deutsch und
darum werde ich einen tag deutsch mit
meiner kumpel
in deutschland wird viel bier getrunken
als gebiete wie eine medienwelt möbius
viel bremer aus deutschland von 15
jahren auch für weniger leute zwei
millionen und auch von sind erwachsene
leute
wir singen so dummen bei 1 millionen
hektoliter ein jahr aus das ist
eigentlich sehr viel im vergleich zu
deutschland
das war unsere video aus der brauerei
wir hoffen euch hat es gefallen danke
fritzen bis bald